the best players always follow the best
players they want to be in the top of
the the game because they are the ones
they are there you know you cannot rest
or sleep because the other one can pass
you of course we fight with everyone
with the Neymar with the Messi with
Lewandowski with iguane you know with
the top of the best players in the world
so I mean this is not fighting but it's
it's it's hard it's healthy you know
compressions is healthy and we fight you
know to be the best this is why it's my
my main point it's my motivation it's to
be better than them than them year after
year and he said to me Cristiano
the most important thing I knew it and
everyone know that and he said Cristiano
we have money
we have everything we have Fame and they
say I have millions and billions but the
most important thing is the family keep
your family healthy good and take care
of your family because this is the most
important thing in the world a part of
that of course you have your life your
private life you have your girlfriend
you have your cars your houses your Fame
but in the beginning your family it's
always with you for the good moments and
for the bad moments but I know I depend
on many people but to be honest
if you're thinking too much about that
you lost your focus which is the most
important you know my focus is to be a
good man
and to do it my my job properly so this
is what I'm trying to do I know many
people depend on me but this is his
other side of me I I try to done so
don't focus on that because in my it's
important but for me is not the most
important it's about the balance we have
time for everything
you know to enjoy with my son
to do it proper my job you know to be
fit all the time to training properly
all the time to play good because it's
my life you know as you know the soccer
in America right and football in Europe
you know it's it's it's great and it's
my passion it's what I love to do and to
be fit all the time to be in the top of
the level many many years you have to be
consistent so this is what I'm trying to
do to be to be good to be in a good
shape and try to enjoy the people this
is what I love to do I have to improve
and I'm I want to improve
and I see myself to do it when I'm
retired to speak from
millions of people
advices
how to be a professional player how to
maintain your longevity how
I'm not psychologist but I passed
through many many things and I can you
know about this above how to win how to
win which is the most important I think
that's what it's all about I have
experienced to to expire people
for that I think I'm I'm a role model
and I I can help many many people in
that way if they want my help I want to
listen to it right for sure especially
the young people I want to be with the
young people to speak with them not only
for them but for the Fathers as well to
put him in a in a white spot I see
football now as a business to be honest
I don't understand that treat you they
treat your players like a piece of meat
and say yes you say everything is true
when they want you when they they they
they count with you they give you
everything when they don't they try to
to make a hard life to you
I see football piece the last years as a
business I saw many many things that I'm
disappointing the passion for the game
is still intact but in the same way I
say I saw other things as well
which is this
surprise me but in the same way
it's part of the business because if you
see the world how it is in the moment
it's it's all business everyone take on
itself everyone they are more individual
listen you have one game after three
four days you have to be in the national
team preparation for the World Cup it's
hard sometimes you have to sell
everything and be with your family take
the best decisions and
in this summer I didn't feel comfortable
I feel uncomfortable the way they treat
me especially the the Press they doubt
about me the professional that I am it's
impossible to be 21 in the top of the
game if you're not professional then
they doubt about me which has made me
feel very very very sad because in my
life I'm always one of the best
professionals this is why I'm still
playing the eye level
I'm always say it's it's all package you
know first of all it's the talent helps
a lot of course but of course the ethic
of work you have to put in your mind
ethic of work when you are professional
so since day one when I started with the
professional let's say with 16 17 18 I'm
always epic to be the best trying hard
to listen to all the players experienced
players and of course my dreaming coming
through I was professional I play in the
best clubs in the worlds I won the most
important trophies so I'm glad to be in
this position but of course this is not
coming from the sky I dedicate myself
and I'm working hard and this is why the
goals and all the achievements that I
get coming from dedication and hard work
in the beginning when I was a young very
young I read a lot and I do extra
trainings to improve my you know my
skills
the dribblings and everything but uh you
know we I think you're working well
because you know I'm what I am today is
started from from that moment that I
that I that I did weights and my feet
and jumping and do drillings and I take
it off and I feel more faster so it was
was funny and I remember so good and I'm
happy to have this memory
um what I did the last
let's say 15 years so it's good it's
good Improvement
I'm always say it was the uh toughest
time in my life it was when I left my
family with 11. years old to live in a
different world which is Lisbon
in the same country but it looked like
it's a
different part of the world I was crying
almost every day to miss my family but
I'm not I'm not regret
because it was probably the more more
intense moments in my life that I that I
lived through
so without sacrifice you cannot win
nothing so I did a unbelievable
sacrifice my family too and I think it
was I think I have I did a good option
it's stupid question what do people say
ah they are not the same nobody is the
same
day by day we're getting old every one
of us you understand it's normal you
have to adapt and I think nobody in this
game have this brain that adapts with
his age I'm not I'm not want to be cocky
to say that I'm the same that when I
asked 20 of course no but I'm adapt and
I be smart to know my strength when I'm
good to do and I'm still playing the eye
level and I score goals and I will
continue to score goals if my mind is
clear and happy and if the people
surround me there help me to be
successful player especially the coach
president directives but when you feel
that the energy don't go surround you
it's difficult you to be yourself which
is happening this is what's happened
with me when I arrive in Manchester
United I always be available to help the
team to do the good things to put in the
right spots to compete with the best
teams but it's hard when they they cut
your legs and they don't like you to
shine and they don't listen to your
advices I think I I have Awards to
advice to the club because the trophies
that I won individual and Collective I
think I can help a lot but when the
infrastructure is not
good they criticized me when I don't
speak of course when I'm gonna speak the
Koreans criticize me even more but it's
something that I can I can deal with
that I know I'm gonna disappointing a
few people maybe I'm gonna make up a few
people but it is what it is the life is
it's completely
difficult we have obstacles in our lives
and um
I will keep running to fight against the
people who don't believe me and the life
is a challenge and I wanted people the
people that they are wrong nobody is
perfect episodes in the life we all have
uh is part of
the human beings it's part of me to be a
human being and father as well
I always will commit a mistakes
but I don't know it's hard to tell right
now what's going to happen the World Cup
because my focus is always for the World
Cup for the Portugal national team